yeah you know what it's it's it's one of
those things you don't want to go back
to the well very often and I know
because when i did it and when you guys
did your goodbyes promised the first
campaign we were like way in the
beginning of of the whole phenomena
where people were really really
interested in giving us attention from a
lot of film blog sites and people just
donated because of the novelty of it
they wanted to see if succeed but now
again in 2013 there's one every day from
somebody new and somebody like somebody
you know and it's just hard to keep up
and try to you know support everyone I
think I if I were to do it it wouldn't
be for any significant amount it's
obviously nowadays it's a marketing tool
you see a lot of people doing it that
get noticed in film festival programmers
say they actually scour the crowdfunding
websites as well so if I were to do it
it'd be something for just you know a
smaller nominal thing where I know I can
make it but it's mainly just to market
to whatever project I'm working
that's probably the only time I would
unless of course you never say never you
know the situation can look like it's
the only way and i'm gonna give the shot
and you know and you think it's been
enough time between projects where you
have enough a new fan base where it's
not the same old people than you know
Never Say Never
you